bonjour françois patriat mou merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin sénateur de la côte de leur
président du groupe rdpc le groupe des
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
ici au sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
bertrand toujours christel tout-montréal
bonjour vont venir christelle du groupe
la dépêche bien évidemment on commence
par la crise sanitaire la situation est
en train de s'aggraver c'est olivier
verront qu'il a dit hier devant les
députés 47000 nouvelles contaminations
en 24 heures c'est un record depuis le
printemps les courbes montrent est-ce
qu'il faut prendre des mesures
supplémentaires je pense qu'il faut
attaquer cette nouvelle vague qui est
une vague violente qui vient après
d'autres pays d'europe qui sont d'europe
qui nourrit aujourd'hui dans des
conditions tout à fait différente dans
des conditions nous nous connaissons
mieux la maladie nous sommes le pays le
mieux armé avec le vaccin ou nous
poursuivons les gestes barrière il est
certain qu'il y a eu des relâchements
ici ou là je crois que les mesures qui
sont prises aujourd'hui de décidé de
vacciner tout le monde de partir de 18
ans le disney de vacciner les enfants
quand ils ont des comorbidités ou qu'ils
ont des risques de le faire maintenant
ce sont des mesures qui permettront
d'endiguer mais aujourd'hui il y a le
taux d'incidence c'est vrai il y as mais
est ce qu'il faut surveiller c'est le
cas de spitz alisation et
d'hospitalisation grade en réanimation
pour voir comment ce drame et mental
c'est d'avoir l'effet de la vaccination
que la vaccination pour les gens qui
n'ont qu'une ou qui n'ont que deux doses
ce n'est pas parfait parce que le taux
d'anticorps n'est pas suffisant et donc
il faut à tout prix tout prix je crois à
activer les mesures qu'il faut prendre
ces jours à activer la troisième dose le
plus possible pour les gens qui ont plus
de cinq mois que tous les gens qui ont
plus cinq fois se fassent vacciner et
c'est fait aujourd'hui mais pour le
reste de ta grande des mesures
coercitives ce qui voudrait dire refaire
du confinement rebloqué l'économie sans
doute pas aujourd'hui je crois que le
taux de vaccination en france le taux de
prémonition que nous avons fait nous
permet aujourd'hui de garder une france
en activité vous dites troisième dose
vacciner tout le monde aujourd'hui la
dépêche du midi fait son dossier sur la
question il n'y a plus de place pour
aller se faire vacciner à toulouse et
dans la région est ce qu'on a rien
appris finalement des vagues précédentes
insulté moi je me souviens quand même
deux il ya quelques temps quelques mois
où les gens voulaient passer un bac es
né souvenez vous il ya eu une
manifestation d'yvan bienvenue je pense
que moi ce que je sais de ce que dit le
ministre de ce que me disent les
praticiens par ailleurs c'est que nous
ne manquerons pas de vaccin donc on pas
de vaccins connaît donc la pharmacienne
vous savez les pharmaciens qui disait
formations ont été les premiers à
demander il n'avait pas le droit de
vacciner au début maintenant ils disent
en intro de travail puisqu'on est passé
de trois vaccins à 50 d'un jour bon tout
est maintenant les pompiers vaccine il
faudrait ouvrir les vaccinodromes il
faut que tout le monde s'y met l'aide
que je crois que les ars mobilise
aujourd'hui avec les préfets les maires
pour réouvrir les centres de vaccination
qui ont été fermés je suis pas inquiet
sur le fait qu'on perd on va y arriver
mais surtout ne paniquons pas devant
deux choses d'abord ce qui nous attend
aujourd'hui c'est une vague les contacts
du vaccin delta est ce que la question
que nous devons nous poser et ça nous
l'aurons dans huit ou neuf jours
maintenant dix jours au maximum est-ce
que ce vaccin résiste est-ce que ce
virus là ça c'est un vrai question
essentielle qui y était mais mon avis
des
vaccinations sa patrie un gouvernement
qui encourage fortement à la vaccination
pourquoi ne pas aller je perds la
vaccination obligatoire l'allemagne
réfléchit son futur chancelier s'est dit
favorable à y venir en france mais moi
je j'entends bien acquis si l'opposition
a demandé si la gauche l'a demandé
on a eu beaucoup de difficultés avec les
mesures imposées pour le personnel
soignant vous avez vu vous voyez ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui outre mer avec
l'obligation vaccinale moi je crois que
l'obligation vaccinale c1 est valable
que si on peut la réaliser comment vous
allez vous allez connaître les gens dans
les entreprises on connaît les gens mais
parmi les retraités parmi les gens qui
sont les indépendants comment vous allez
savoir si on vacciner ou pas comment
vous allez chercher les gens je crois
qu'il faut mieux il faut mieux faire ce
qui est possible et réaliste que de
décréter ce qui n'est pas possible à
réaliser alors aujourd'hui vous dites il
faut il faut resserrer un peu les
mesures reprendre en compte les gestes
barrière or dans les écoles les mesures
sont de plus en plus lâche on lève
certaines restrictions les français sont
un petit peu perdues comment vous
expliquez ça si on ne lève pas les leurs
et les restrictions on a changé un peu
le père durant dix ans on les eaux les
tests tout le monde seulement tellier
positifs sont pas les concerts publics
classe parce que d'abord pour les
enfants je crois qu'ils ont déjà
beaucoup donné en perdant des hordes de
classe et en second lieu pour les
parents bien compris que les parents qui
aujourd'hui à l'école ça crée aussi des
problèmes pour le travail pour le reste
donc je crois qu'on a soufflé dans le
bon sens sans mettre en danger pour
autant je crois la vidéo lol le
personnel inquiet oui le personnel est
toujours à quai à chaque fois que des
mesures de prises à chaque fois ils ont
contesté donc maintenant
nous sommes tous des inquiétudes mais
bien sûr que c'est justifié quand on
connaît les rend bien et puis non ce que
je crois atteint les français
aujourd'hui et ça si cela contre eux
contre lesquels psychologiquement c'est
un phénomène de lassitude des français
qui se disent on va pas on va jamais en
sortir il y aura toujours des variants
et je crois que ce qu'il faut aussi s
activer la vaccination en france mais
sous dans le monde il faut que là il
faut que l'ensemble est à laboratoires
et autres puissent faire en sorte que le
maximum de personnes dans le monde soit
vaccinée pour éviter la naissance du
nouveau variant sébastien lecornu le
ministre d outre-mer termine aujourd'hui
sa visite dans les antilles et en proie
à des manifestations à des violences les
violences perdurent malgré sa visite les
négociations échouent est ce que cette
visite est un échec
chaque fois qu'il ya des difficultés on
en a connu par le passé dans l'est dans
les outre-mer
la solution de la violence pour les pays
qui dérivent du sujet initial en est
partie du sujet sanitaires pour aller
sur un sujet social avec des
revendications sociales qui sont pas à
100 c'est par ailleurs mais dans
longtemps des dérapages violents contre
lesquels il faut le fait de pouvoir
exiger le rétablissement de l'ordre
avant de discuter me paraît lâche une
chose essentielle comment peut-on
discuter sous la pression comment
peuvent discuter alors que dans le même
temps il ya des tirs à balles réelles
sur les policiers ou sur des
journalistes c'est pas penser c'est ce
qui se passe en flammes elle m'emmène
ouvre des discussions alors que oui mais
lorsque la semaine dernière savez
certains nous reprocher elles du fait
que le ministre ne soit pas déjà là bas
laurent labit attendait pour l'instant
est ce qu'il n'y ait pas les mélanger je
ne pense pas parce que à partir du
moment où on accepte d'y aller d'abord
céder immédiatement à la violence il ya
laissé ses dénommé bien sûr y aller à
l'essai immédiatement dire juste on peut
pas discuter sans avoir dit aux gens
attendent et maintenant je veux bien
qu'on parle de certains choses encore il
ya des avancées qui ont été faites on a
repoussé jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin
décembre la vaccination des soignants
85% des soignants sont vaccinés
leur nom mais renard de ce fait on
renvoie des renforts on renvoie des
gendarmes on voit jgl rencontrons à côté
pour faire en sorte n'a je crois qu'il
faut d'abord faire comprendre parce que
vous aviez vu là bas des gens qui
disaient nous ne renonçons pas à la
violence nous ne dénonçons pas la
violence nous l'excluons malgré tout
devant continuer peut-être est-ce que
vous pensez que dans une république
normale face à un ministre dit non mais
pas du tout la violence et normalise non
non je crois que je crois que l'autorité
c'est aussi une des formes d'art de la
république il faut respecter mais quand
le gouvernement en recul justement sur
la date de vaccination ouvrent le débat
sur l'autonomie certains notamment chez
les républicains julien aubert vous
accuse d'avoir céder à la violence et
d'avoir ouvert c'est ces discussions
parce qu'il y avait des actes violents
mais notre bien non peut pas d'un côté
demander à ce conseil deloitte et le
jour on s'est dit on a cédé feuillage
j'entendais julia robert ne recule
devant aucune contradiction c'est leur
rôle ils sont en campagne électorale
c'est l'opposition tout est critiquée je
suis bien que
je pense que je voulais je crois que les
ont mal compris ce que voulait dire
autonomie ce qu il ya de l autonomie
encore aujourd'hui il ya des pays du
pacifique son autonomie et qui vivent
parfaitement eux c'est l'autonomie c'est
pas la vendre le mot peut surprendre que
pour certains ont compris qu'on allait
le rendre données indépendance le fait
qu'on puisse gérer le droit à la
différenciation revendiquée par les
régions françaises il peut être aussi
revendiquée par les territoires
d'outre-mer or là c'est autonomie
proposée par le gouvernement c'est un
droit à la différenciation voilà donc
les panneaux est ce que les corps
justement des demandes plus d'autonomie
dont il une majorité autonomiste est-ce
que c'est pas un peu ouvrir la boîte de
pandore et dans ces cas là pourquoi
faire le débat dans les antilles parce
qu'il ya des violences et à l'ouvrir en
commun mais encore ce que tu ne me tous
leurs cris il ya aujourd'hui l'assemblée
de corse et il ya des jeunes forme
d'autonomie en corse il existe alors que
ceux qui l'auront pour lui fallait pas
contrôler comme cette différenciation
renfort moi je pense voilà c'est ça on
va parler du budget puisque le sénat a
entamé hier une série de débats
budgétaires alors ces débats qui se
déroulent parce que le sénat la majorité
de droite au sénat a refusé de voter le
projet de loi de finances il a rejeté la
première partie ce qui a fait tomber le
budget c'est des débats budgétaires que
vous boycottez pourquoi ce ne sont pas
des débats budgétaires ce sont des
débats
électoraux prenant les thématiques des
candidats qui vont se départager
dimanche
accusateurs accusateurs cd l'intitulé du
débat c'est la ja til trop d'aléas t-il
trop d'insécurité en france les titres
de dettes en france moi je suis un peu
sur
déjà
depuis que depuis quatre ans le sénat et
la chambre de l'opposition le président
le dit lui-même nous sommes l'opposition
bien mais quand l'opposition mais qui
reste évident d attaquer tout prix
constructive ne pas voter le budget est
ce que c'est constructif
quand on quand on a voté en commission
que tu aimes bien jours et vous
compreniez en commission la première
partie de la probabilité recettes de
l'hautil ans ils ont été votés article
par article ont été voter jusqu'au bout
les communistes ont été cohérents ils
ont qui se pose une question préalable
on ne discute pas du budget
les républicains n'ont pas voté on
arrive à la fin ils disent on ne veulent
pas l'article d'un côté donc après avoir
tout voté après avoir fait passer des
amendements moi j'ai dit à un moment où
rapporteur du budget on marche sur la
tête il m'a répondu c'est pas la
première fois non j'entends bien je vais
bien bon et je n'arrive au bout et on ne
vote pas les recettes comment voulez
vous qu'on vote les dépenses qu'on va
pas voter les recettes mais la soul ce
que ce qui me choque un peu c'est de
voir que le sénat qui revendique
toujours on n'est pas assez concertée on
ne consulte pas assez on ignore le
parlement au piétine le parlement le
jour il a devant sa responsabilité
essentielle qui est voté le budget on en
discute plus enfin une assemblée dans le
rôle c'est de contrôler le gouvernement
est de voter le budget qui dit je veux
pas le budget pourquoi ne veulent-elles
pas pourquoi ne le vote pas j'ai dit
pour des raisons électorales mais aussi
parce qu'ils sont l'opposition et très
mal parce qu'il y a dans ce budget des
mesures régaliennes qui concerne la
défense la santé l'école la sécurité des
mesures qu'ils auraient aimé voter eux
mêmes mais qu'ils n'ont jamais voté qui
n'ont jamais voté et de ce fait là
aujourd'hui ils sont très mal à l'aise
alors plutôt que de faire acte de
contrition si je puis dire il préfère ne
pas discuter du budget est embarqué dans
deux débats
vous répondre que c'est un budget
électoraliste avec trop de dépendances
attendez on peut pas dire dans le même
temps qu'il faut plus de moyens pour la
justice qu'il faut plus face aux grands
des comptes parce que la justice tout le
monde dit pour la justice quand il ya un
budget que 8 8% de hausse qui s'est
jamais vue républicain justice et les
républicains disent qu'à trop dépenser
dans le même temps on demande plus
d'argent pour la sécurité pour l'école
pour la santé pour la défense et le jour
où les votes c'est électoraliste dont
judas pour aller au bout est ce que s'il
était allé au bout du budget vous auriez
tenu compte de leur modification du rsa
c'est ça c'est le rôle du parlement il
ya des amendements que nous avons voté
d'ailleurs le point pour bien vous
pouvez regarder le nombre de deux textes
de lois de payer proposition de loi où
il ya eu une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive
sur l'indemnité inflation les sénateurs
n'ont pas voté ils ont proposé un
dispositif alternatif la majorité
présidentielle n'en n'a pas nommé la
paye de compromis des poteaux lui serait
du coup vous comprenez que danser
lorsque la mesure il a mende ma méthode
et je vous rappelle ce lot regardons
bien là encore le côté surprenant
le la majorité sénatoriale dit c'est un
cadeau électoral de faire aujourd'hui
une mesure anti inflation les français
apprécieront qui vont avoir 100 euros
supplémentaires au delà des 150 euros
deux fois dans l'année ils apprécieront
trois fois dans la pression savez le
littoral dont on n'est pas d'accord mais
eux on propose un autre en promo
aussitôt un autre qui est aussi un
cadeau électoral mais qui est très très
mal ciblés et qui touche beaucoup moins
de monde je pense que le gouvernement
est responsable dit l'inflation touche
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui
essayons de faire en sorte que
l'éventail soit large et faisons donc là
il ya désaccord profond mais aux moyens
et aux discussions une dernière question
avant de passer à la présidentielle avec
christelle dernière question sur le
scénar sur le parlement les députés qui
ont donc voté le prolongement légal du
vg de douze à quatorze semaines c'est
les députés qui ont voulu notamment
christophe castaner qui a voulu ce texte
soit que soit ce texte soit réintroduit
dans le calendrier parlementaire le plus
vite possible il a eu raison selon vous
le mot jeu d'abord christophe est mon
ami les choses soient claires légendes
sont manière qu'amélie genre de son
groupe ce sont mes amis non est ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que parce que
je vous donnais mes positions ce que
vous connaissez a décidé le groupe est
un des pays au sénat
la majorité à l'assemblée est libre et
responsable de son ordre du jour et des
choix qu'elle fait comme nous nous
faisons des choix que nous faisons nous
avons une seule peut nous pour ce qui
nous concerne une seule niche qui sera
le 12 janvier nice à l'endroit où on
peut placer une ppl tu cliques ppm
app-ps et m les deux façons il ya deux
façons maintenant il a des façons
maintenant que le texte avance il
comprendre que le texte le sénat le
gouvernement a dit ça j'ai sur ce texte
à l'assemblée nous nous avait déjà un
nom ne s'est pas prononcé un port et dry
sagesse il rédige laisse bon bien
maintenant
christophe souhaite que le texte passe
at-il personnel s'il vient d'ici je le
voterai c'est pas moi c'est pas un
problème pour ce qui me concerne moi
c'est pas une proposition de mapa et or
il a laissé libre libre vote à tous les
membres de aussi bien au modem que dans
les groupes majoritaires ou bien nous
avons fait le choix nous avons insultes
fenêtre de tir le 12 janvier de prendre
un sujet qui nous tient à coeur c'est le
harcèlement scolaire nous pensons
aujourd'hui que l'enseignement scolaire
est un vrai fléau de société pour les
enfants et que c'est très dangereux et
que c'est très dangereux et c'est une
ppl déposé je crois par le groupe modem
et une partie de la majorité absolue et
nous avons montré ce texte là ça ne veut
pas dire qu'elle ne veut pas dire que
nous n'en voulons pas ça veut dire que
l'assemblée l'a voté très bien je pense
qu'ils n'exercent ble ment on y arrivera
mais ce sera le sujet il y aura pas de
place au sénat pour qu'il soit discuté
dans notre mission dans notre nichane ou
non dans notre édition puisque nous
avons un texte réglementaire qui
si il peut très bien aller c'est le
gouvernement décide de le mettre le
gouvernement à la possible
le greffe a poussé le gouvernement à
écouter
fenêtres calendrier parlementaire ou
c'est pas un problème si la page à titre
personnel je souhaite sur le
gouvernement qui le fasse voilà très
bien parce que nous nous avons si vous
pensiez vous s'il n'y avait pas pris le
harcèlement scolaire on n'irait
pas fait non je crois qu'on a fait ce
choix là je vous dis si ce texte là moi
je souhaite qu'un gouvernement le met un
moment si dans les sièges avec quoi le
gouvernement scolaire que le
gouvernement le même si le choix j'en ai
parlé avec christophe castaner et le
premier ministre avant-hier on a évoqué
le sujet de discussion complique avec
beaucoup de gens plus tôt christophe
castaner lui souhaiterait que le madex
obama étudie aussi les comprends mais
zip été blessés il peut l'être
oui ouais eric zemmour hier annoncé sa
candidature officiellement cette fois ci
à l'élection présidentielle tout d'abord
est ce que cela exclure si un petit peu
le jeu politique
après moi je n'ai pas pour habitude de
parler de parler beaucoup d'eric zemmour
sipa pourrais-tu me fall je vais
répondre à vos questions bien entendu
parce que j'ai vu qu'hier soir j'ai
regardé il a eu des difficultés à
répondre aux journalistes entrée en
campagne électorale sur un tank est
plutôt agressif de ne pas vouloir
répondre de dire en sortant c'était avec
les histoires je crois qu'il doit
s'attendre à quelques semaines s'ils
continuent comme ça difficile pour ce
qui le concerne bien non c'est pas une
surprise on savait très bien qu'il avait
mis en place une organisation qui
l'avait trouvé des locaux qu'il avait un
directeur de cabinet que c'est qu'il
avait transformée en réunion électorale
les meetings de signatures de livres
donc ce n'est pas une surprise ce que
j'ai trouvé hier c'est que j'ai trouvé
une mise en scène
dans la dramaturgie malsaine voire
lugubre et en même temps mais là vous
parlez glg homo je dis moi hier un peu
sacrilège parce que je ne connais aucun
aurait pu apaiser je ne connais aucun
grand aurait pu pauliste qui s'est
permis un jour dit michael général de
bull jamais jamais jamais et l'utiliser
en plus avec des images avec des images
captées non pays d'après ce que j'ai
compris en plus pour dramatiser sur une
seule thématique il ne sort pas de sa
thématique meilleur soir dans sa
déclaration de candidature sur une
chaîne nationale j'ai vu hier soir il
est resté dans sa thématique il l'a un
peu mise en retrait dans sa danse et
vidéo itier l'immigration certes mais
avant tout l'économie faut
réindustrialiser le pays maintenant non
et là dedans il dit vous devez vous
n'êtes plus dans le pays vous est connu
souvenez vous la nostalgie du passé vous
savez c'était mieux avant j'ai toujours
entendu ça c'était mieux avant 1 j'ai
même entendu des gens quand j'étais
enfant qui disait vaudrait mieux de
guerre pour que ça aille mieux c'est
bien on veut qu'elles passent et on l'a
vu avec joséphine baker mais aussi non
lorsqu'il en hommage à jeanne d'arc
enfin il m il aime convoquer le reste
des manuels pas compte dans le discours
extraordinaire qu'il a fait hier emporté
au magnifique magnifique il magnifie la
france éternelle la france des lumières
de france de la démocratie la france
ouverte la france des droits de l'homme
quand monsieur zemmour de l'assurance et
l'école de la même france dont on parle
c'est à dire qu'ils noircissent la
france c'est la france dégradée la
fondue klotz et tous avaient la terre ne
ment pas c'est tout ça c'est du cynisme
s'est redressée mais c'est du passé que
le passé plutôt que de parler de
l'avenir comment l'un comme l'autre
qu'on veut que le passé plutôt que
marcher dans ses pas vrai parce que la
cote emmanuel mâcon s'exprime que vous
parle du passé comme il a parlé hier
comme on a parlé avec beaucoup de beauté
de profondeur et hier ça veut dire on
dit le passé le passé éclaire l'avenir
le passé éclaire l'avenir alors
qu'aujourd'hui ce que dit et ce que
disent je veux dit zemmour c'est le
passé me fait regretter l'avenir c'est
tout à fait différent comme comme
projection tout à fait différent alors
depuis plusieurs mois l'elysée dit
craindre une candidature populiste emma
venant de la société civile les ellison
est ce que non c'est ce qu'ils nous
disaient nous on n'est jamais
sûr
est-ce que la candidature d'eric zemmour
est inquiétante ou est-ce qu'au
contraire elle sert le futur candidat
emmanuel macron en divisant les voix de
la droite il peut se remettre
inversement je pourrais vous dire que si
elle est si elle affaiblit marine le pen
et qu'elle est qu'elle affaiblit marine
le pen elle sert les républicains
je vous retourne la question
en tout cas je pense que c'est sur ce
sujet je crois que le chef de l'état qui
voit les choses qui connaît très bien la
politique qui anticipait qui a une
vision
c'est très bien aujourd'hui ce que
représente comme danger mais ne me
convainc pas tout le danger eric zemmour
bien moi ce que je ne sais pas c'est
quand on interroge
en disant est ce que ça prend chez vous
eric zemmour m'interrogeais compris
quand le président est venu à beaune est
ce que ça prend vraiment pas parler
comme ça mais on parle hémolytique voilà
ici il va à l'accueil très chaleureux ça
se passe bien mais répond - oui ça prend
un prix mais je ne pense pas que ça
durerait gelé d'il ya deux mois je les
dis à moi je ne pense que ça ne voudra
pas parce que parce que je crois que une
fois pas une qui a pu aller marcher au
début parce que les gens ont envoyé 10
compense un lui puis 7 vous avez vu il
ya cette traque contre les élites entre
vous contre les politiciens on a
l'habitude loin d'accord mais contre
problème contre les forces de
représentant les églises on vous ment
moi je ne vous mens pas on est dans les
clous on vous ment tous les jours alors
sur le coup ça peut dire oui c'est vrai
on se moque de nous on nous dit pas tout
bon mais après quand on voit comment
s'est-il je dirais que comment s'est
déroulé sa compagne après le bataclan un
prêt le doigt d'honneur à marseille et
d'autres et d'autres condamnations à
côté on voit bien que d'excès en excès
la réalité le vrai visage apparaît d'un
polémiste qui n'arrive pas à passer du
stade de polémiste au stade proposant
entre entre polémiques et est proposé et
je pense que rend continuant il aurait
fallu après marseille une rupture dans
le candidat qui montre que c'est autre
chose or il a continué dire sur ça sur
sa ligne d'avants
sans cette rupture je crois qu'il exhale
le mans il sera l'heure de vitesse
parlons de votre famille politique vous
étiez lundi soir à la mutualité où vous
avez célébré la naissance de ensemble
citoyens qui est la maison commune qui
doit regrouper les différentes familles
politiques qui vont soutenir emmanuel
macron à l'élection présidentielle s'il
est candidat est ce que c'est a vocation
à devenir un parti ensemble citoyen
d'abord c'était un bel événement pas
très souligné j'ai vu sur les médias sa
déco tient debout aux événements n'en
parle pas quand il ya des drames on en
parle tous les jours mais nous sommes là
encore aussi bien mais on en parle c'est
drôle on parle j'ai pas vu beaucoup
d'image mais enfin on n'en parle bien
c'est un événement qui acquit montrer
quoi une chose 1
les mouvements et les partis qui
soutiennent le gouvernement sont
rassemblés et pas de façon factice j'ai
participé à titre personnel aux réunions
la création
donc je peux vous le dire pas factice
une volonté de discussions de débats
mais d'aboutir d'aboutir à ce qu'on soit
ensemble 2 que ce premier mouvement
mérite d'être approfondie il y aura des
approfondissements dans ce mouvement je
crois dérapages un rapprochement il y
aura des rapprochements plus concret
aujourd'hui nous avons une bannière
commune nous avons une vision commune et
nous préparons à la fois la candidature
des manières qu'ont s'il est candidat
quand il sera candidat et je le souhaite
à titre personnel je le soutiendrai
comme j'ai soutenu sans état d'âme en
2016 2017 ils ont en même temps nous
préparons aussi le futur il nous faudra
demain parce qu'il faut il faut que pour
réussir ce quinquennat et la france en a
besoin il faut une victoire forte je
l'espère du chef de l'état il faut une
majorité il faut une majorité que de
moyens fort et uni en tennis c'est
pouvoir faire les réformes qui n'ont pas
pu être fait pendant ce que c'est ce que
françois bayrou appelle de ses voeux
c'est à dire qu'il pourra y avoir des
partenariats entre deux îles pourrions
être sûr c'est loin des personnages pour
ces jeux peut être que ça doit aller
jusqu'à la fin de la république en
marche ou qui avait créé qu'un parti
pirate a sion la république en mach est
ce que ça te pas la fin de la république
en marche est ce qu'il faut tout
refonder dans un parti mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les français n'aiment pas
les parties et se méfie de tous les
partis tous les poteaux les grands
partis historiques de ce pays sont mis à
mal et suscitent le doute chez les
français faut-il
moi je lui dis on l'a toujours dit que
vous avez nous on marche on est dans un
mouvement
à côté nous avons agir est un mouvement
nous sommes fiers à partie aujourd'hui
je crois que tu avais la formule c'est
pas moi qui la donne c'est le chef de
l'état une élection la politique ce
n'est pas une addition de chapelle c'est
une dit
aujourd'hui pourquoi je ne vois pas non
aujourd'hui la plus grande marche il ya
des gens qui sont marcheurs quels gens
qui sont marcheurs qui ne sont pas à
horizon il pourrait y avoir des
partenariats renforcés entre la
république en marche et le modem par
exemple tout à fait je pense et je pense
les ardeurs il était d'accord avec ça
parce que ça va arriver mais
edouard philippe je veux dire on ne peut
pas être contre mais peuvent ni pau et
ses deux passes et deux parties qui se
rapprochent qui se rapproche et qui n'a
pas semblé tirer ensemble mais il aura
pas son mal et avec le bas dans le méli
peut se rapprocher aussi avec nous je
pense que pas s'ils le font c'est pas de
problème non mais c'est à dire et pas le
sens de sa malice corio lundi soir jeune
mais je ne vois pas comment s'y savez le
maire j'ai dit je trouvais très beau le
discours de d'edouard philippe sur le
dépassement il a fait comme une pré une
prestation disons voilà pour moi ce
qu'est le dépassement et le dépassement
répond totalement à vos questions ici
c'est la maison commune
[Musique]